[Music]
hi
Jesus we came behind the stadium where
the elephant's performed and we found
this juvenile elephant on here the
gaping red wounds at his temple he also
has a broken leg the other one is
chained up he looks totally emaciated
skin and bones and this is the worst
shape I've seen an elephant in Thailand
all in the name of entertainment
[Music]
wildlife tourism is a massive industry
accounting for 10 to 20 percent of the
global tourism industry people go on
vacation and pay money to either view or
interact with animals I don't think we
can ignore the role that social media
plays the sheer number of people now not
only posting their travel experiences
but consuming others travel experiences
means that these things are spread in an
instant with the click of a button
but the issue of with wildlife tourism
is most people have absolutely no idea
of what goes on behind the scenes
I reported this story on wildlife
tourism with photographer Kirsten Luce
for a year and we set out knowing that
we really had to sort of narrow our
focus and go to kind of hotspots around
the world where this industry is a
massive part of the local economy but
there was nothing that prepared me for
what I actually saw in the field
especially when we went to Thailand
[Music]
this is a place that puts on monkey
shows and I think the see behind me this
movie is in a small metal cage you see
is jumping over and over and over and
this is called zoo kosis and animals
that are trapped in captivity do this
when they're in psychological distress I
[Music]
here at assume form of a shopping mall
in Bangkok this kind of place animals
are Libyan conditions that no living
beings should be living in the only
gorillas in Thailand is apparently in
the zoo the gorilla was reaching attend
to through the cage onto a puddle on the
concrete floor and scooping up finger
holes of water I seem to be the only way
this thriller could access water we just
finished watching the crocodile show
which is pretty disturbing and consisted
of two trainers dragging crocodiles
around my details smacking them on the
head with sticks and then I'm rolling
with laughs it was like all designed as
a comedy routine
on most people's bucket list we're going
to Thailand you're gonna want to see an
elephant so we went to dozens of
elephant experiences all over Thailand
mahute trainers that care for their
elephants used their bull hooks on
elephants to get them to pose to allow
tourists to take photos with them a bull
hook is a stick and at the end of the
wooden stick is a metal prong or hook
and this is the instrument used to
control an elephant
I'm here met him on elephant camp in
Chiang Mai I think the most shocking
thing was doing an actual show some of
these will have had nails on the end I
witnessed a couple from the hoops that
had nails in their hands that they were
poking behind that was here to get them
to perform and do the painting I don't
know if it may mean a she's four years
old and she performed in the show she
painted her picture so she did have a
nail in her ear and after the show we
walked over to where she was being kept
there was a chain around her leg that
had spikes in it the spikes were all the
way around pressing into her skin she
was kind of covering it in the air
because obviously it hurts foot weight
on it and I asked her who won and he
said it's because she likes to kick her
mahute said that he puts it on for a
little while to teacher and then he
takes it off at night I decided that I
wanted to come back later to see if she
actually was on a different chain with
permission of the facility we ended up
coming back six hours later and I feel
like before I got to her I just knew
about 7:30 p.m. a good see it's getting
dark and it's pouring rain ena has had a
spike hanging around her ankle since we
last left her so I don't know how she's
gonna sleep and it's really really
upsetting to watch it was the first time
I sorta witnessed deception that sort of
runs through this industry and I wanted
to see for myself where these animals
are born how they're trained the
economics behind this industry and if
you want to go to ground zero basically
off the elephant industry in Thailand
you have to go to bond town club there
are 3,500 captive elephants in the
country and half of them are actually
sourced to Pontic lon it's a place where
elephants are bred trained and then when
they are ready they're sold down south
to camps around the country
the Thai government actually offers a
subsidy to boots who care for elephants
there the elephant tourism industry is a
massive source of income for the country
so they they actively fund it ensuring
that the elephant entertainment industry
is healthy and that there are always new
babies being funneled in and that it is
thriving most people in the town are ma
hoots meaning they work with elephants
for a living a young man was happy to be
honest with me about how they train
their elephants and what tourists don't
realize is that in order for an elephant
to be docile enough to stand there and
let you touch him safely that elephant
has to be trained in the same way that
an elephant throwing darts on a show is
trained as a young baby going through
abusive fear-based training what usually
happens is when elephant is about 2
years old the baby is confined and over
several days and weeks the baby is
slowly trained the elephant is kind of
freaking out first thing they teach the
baby is how to sit and so he said they
use a hook at the back and someone pulls
down and then someone uses another hook
at the front and the baby's legs are
tied together and they pull the legs
front and they do this over and over
until the baby learns how to do it he
said to me we have to use the whole hook
so the baby will know knowing that Mina
was four years old and elephants live 80
years they live as long as people do she
was at the beginning of what could be
another 60 65 70 years of this life was
very overwhelming to sort of grapple
with
so it's been three days since we were
last at Mynt amon camp or returning
today just to see what the situation is
and of course check on guna and see how
she's being held at her stall when she's
not performing it's the spiked chain you
watch your foot it's a right foot
she was just out posing with to us then
our monkey just brought her back to her
and put the spike to chain back around
her foot and I'm realizing now that this
is her chain this isn't a chain he uses
sometimes to discipline her this is her
chain
she spin into every time we've seen him
there's no other shame in sight that he
could possibly be switching out its
tethered to the pole if any tourists
sort of thinks like it's okay it's
hurting the animal most places are very
quick with a response to say oh no
they're fine like this it's just the way
it is don't worry about it and that
satisfies most people and they say okay
like they must know what they're doing
they care for the animal the system is
actually designed to be confusing most
tourists I really do believe kind of
want to do the right thing they love
animals and they want to get close to
them it's simple it's understandable and
since 2014 the number of animal selfies
that people have posted has grown almost
300% part of what often inspires people
to go on this trip is because they saw
someone else do it and they want that
experience for themselves however social
media really does go both ways
I wanted to actually visit a couple of
good elephant experiences in Thailand
just to see for myself what that looked
like and how it differed from places
that may call themselves a sanctuary but
offer a lot of interaction so we went to
elephant Valley in China at Islands they
have elephants that have been rescued
from the traditional industry and
tourists are not allowed to get close to
the elephants this is probably the only
interaction that tourists will get while
they're here it's nap time so they're
able to feed each of the elephants some
bananas and you can see this barrier is
there mostly for to prevent people from
going into the elephant elephant grounds
so it's totally voluntary the elephants
come for snack time and then they can
leave whenever they want so it's a
sustainable option for elephant tourism
in the area social media can actually be
harnessed for good you can go to a an
ethical place and use social media to
sort of educate your own communities on
ways that they can be part of the
solution this entire industry is so
incredibly entrepreneurial that it can
and does change on a dime so when people
decide that they no longer want to give
their money to a certain sort of
experience and if enough people do that
then the experience themselves will
shift you the viewer and reader and
traveler and just citizen are at the
heart of this story just as much as
anyone elses you have tremendous power
as a consumer to change things
[Music]